[Music]
full steam ahead is a set of online and
hybrid resources
created by mit for the world it was
created both out of a need for high
quality free resources for changing
learning environment
but also out of mit's passion for
teaching learning
and innovation
[Music]
you're already learning so much in the
program and then you're able to use that
knowledge for
for yourself outside of the program so
the knowledge stays with you
i think they can really like be creative
and use their imagination a lot
i think it can help them like learn new
things and
help them socialize with other people
better
these types of programs are very
innovative because they
uh at least during my experience
they pushed teachers and the mentors of
the online classes particularly in
particular
to find new ways of sharing knowledge i
also learned about how
fulfilling teaching can be even even if
it's difficult i personally focus on
trying to build students confidence
in their ability to solve problems i
want them to be able to see a problem
and not just be like just run into a
wall programs like full steam ahead are
necessary because it is not only
important to learn
concepts like science and math but also
more of the problem solving skills
and the collaboration skills students
were actually
able to collaborate on projects or
help each other with certain problems
they have
students know what other students might
struggle with
so they are actually in a better
position
to help their fellow students
and i have witnessed that
two students were very helpful to each
other i think
full steam ahead is a great example of
something that people can kind of come
together in a time
of need and a time where you know things
kind of seem a little bleak
[Music]
full steam ahead continues to grow
beyond middle school
we're currently running a program with
more than 600 high school students that
are located both in the u.s
and in spain we will continue to share
not only our resources but our passion
for learning and for making the world a
better place